man we we've gotten so we've gotten so
deep deep in the conversation I'm really
excited I hope you have a lot of time
today because I really wanted I want to
dive into everything that you want to go
to yeah here is I'm be honest with you
bro here is my my only criticism of
female content creators such as yourself
okay if I'm being 100 honest with y'all
don't want to ever say anything behind
your background which I won't say to
your face I feel like you guys are
pandering I feel like you guys are
pandering to a certain community of men
who freaking like it's like it's it's
PornHub only fans red pill female
content creators are all that that guess
oh wow that gets them going that gets
them excited right so so I promise
really on the same only thing no no no
no no no no no no no no
wow thank you you can't compete with
them I'm sorry I can't compete with them
okay
so the only the only family the PornHub
is number one like I'm like one to like
yes and then and then where they're the
only fans depending what she's doing are
only fans it could it can go for
anywhere from 9.5 to 8. okay
it so then where did we fall I would say
the men love your content so much it'd
probably be about seven a seven yeah
okay okay so you think you said
pandering so you think I don't actually
believe any of this no no no no no no no
no no that's what I hear Pander I look
that up because people say that a lot
and it basically means you just say
things because you don't believe it and
you just want that so if if I want to
clarify I said I aha if if I if I said
because I don't memory's a bad yeah
recollection if I said you are pandering
I was wrong okay I feel like at times
content creating I didn't say you okay
content creators okay like those yeah
Pander well there's only a couple in the
space in the red pill space that are
women okay so it's not about it's not
about red pill though yeah no okay okay
so so to me let me give you an example
Let me Give an example okay I genuinely
believe that there is a lot of nuance to
your ideas I generally do not believe
you share all your Nuance online I
genuinely believe you're extremely smart
content creator I genuinely believe you
understand what gets clicks views X Y
and Z I genuinely believe that you're an
individual who's very calculating what
you say and what you do so therefore I
was coached by you listen
that's why that's why it breaks my heart
it breaks my it breaks your heart it
really does I'm not gonna lie to you why
because first you first we had an a
session you weren't coached by me yeah I
can't put my stamp on that I'm kidding I
can't put my stamp on that yeah we
having fun we're just having fun all
right so so my belief is that deep down
inside I feel like you're a woman how in
the world do you believe everything a
man believes you should have nuanced
positions that's the beauty of the
masculine feminine where you there's
similarities and there's differences so
when I hear a logical woman I definitely
expect to hear her to communicate things
that the logical male and female
understands but I also expect because
she's a feminine individual and you
believe men and women are different so
therefore if men and women are different
and both of them are communicating their
ideas there's going to be differences
and nuances to their ideas and so
therefore whenever I see not saying you
remember I told you this I don't watch a
lot about this I don't know it but
whenever I see those those Pro male
female content creators and I see like
they always have the same male talking
points and there's no uniquely feminine
talking points that men will agree with
but she stands in that because she is a
woman and her ideas are different
sometimes times I wonder is this person
fully communicating how they feel or are
they at times pandering because they
understand that by communicating this
way to this audience I'm able to do
better not saying you're doing so I want
you to get mad at me I don't know your
attention
I'm just I'm just communicating so when
you brought up the do you want to
respond to that yeah I was leading to
the white school point out of the wife's
school yeah I was just gonna say that I
think it's more having like a father
presence in our lives most of us what
about yourself
um what do you mean what about my mom
you have a motherly presence as well
yeah shout out Jen you call me Mom by
your first name what are you doing girl
that's a white girl stuff boy called
Mama Jake
what the heck
no no I mean it's like um I don't know
it's funny because I would say naturally
if I take a personality test that says
I'm very left it says I'm very liberal
so a lot of people think I'm more like
left when they first meet me but like my
dad was just always there to like dispel
everything he doesn't believe in the
voting thing though he thinks I took
that too far shout out pop
and I'm not picking on you yeah let me
because you made up you made the wife
school I truly believe women like you
this is why I wanted to talk to you I
wanted to say this to you personally I
don't want to do dog care I want to say
to you personally because things make
great content women like you have the
power to change everything you made a
point in this you said you believe women
can make a change I truly believe you're
you're so correct women such as yourself
such as yourself wield so much power to
make a true lasting change in this
Society women such as yourself have a so
much of power and ability to make a true
lasting change in this world yeah I
agree and so to me my biggest thing is
that I want women such as yourself
living out your full potential and your
full skill sets to be able to truly
transform the world and so to me when
you made the wife's School reference I
was like man this I wanted I'm glad you
went there yeah because the first reason
it was are you married no you so that's
why I need wife school that's what I'm
putting it together no no no no no no no
no no no no I can let me look yeah I if
you really want to help women yeah I can
tell you exactly what to do that will be
able to help women here's the reality
when it comes to male content this is
not important they actually think this
is a sign of weakness but this is not
important they don't give a dang if
you're married or not men don't care all
men care is can you have sex can you get
laid if you are a man and you can show
and prove to people that you can have
sex with other women other men will
respect you am I making the rules that
is what happened Us in male contest so
male content creators don't have to be
married for other men to respect them if
they sold some receipts they show curls
on Yahoo girls on parties in the show
whatever it may be other guys will
respect them and listen to them because
that is the litmus test for success and
men not my rules is what's going on
today's world women is different women
respect this women listen to this when
you're able to be like yo you women you
can either be like this like me or be
like this fruits yeah when you're able
to do stuff like that you're not
familiar with my content I don't really
give advice but I know but you said why
school yeah but it's not tough on me huh
it's not tough on me who's gonna build a
wife school yeah I'll put let's just see
if you give let me give the elevator go
ahead please critique the idea please so
that's what I was thinking I was like I
was like oh you know we should do we
should bring in like wives from around
the world that actually are married and
are actually in those positions and you
could like go through different classes
for like how to dress like a wife how to
cook like a wife how to clean like all
the things that like wives have and I
was that's what I was thinking I was
like well I can't teach it I'm not a
wife and I was like but I'm like really
good at bringing people together and I
wouldn't I wouldn't ask someone to do
something that I'm not I'm not willing
to do I love it here's what I was going
to because you're actually saying the
same thing yeah literally what I just
what you describe is one of my ideas
yeah you called the white school I
called the wife Academy oh okay and
it'll be an amazing show I actually gave
it to somebody this is a free game I I
gave it to somebody but you said it
already I um I'm going to give it to the
people wife Academy would be a podcast
where a woman who's married brings in
other women who marry and talks them
about what does it mean to be a wife
because the school is cool but the
school how many people can be in the
school 100 200 300 a thousand is limited
but it would be filmed so it's like I
love it yeah so so let's say you know
it's it's gonna be filmed so in his wife
Academy the fundamental challenge is if
you were gonna start the wife Academy
the people want to know did it work for
you that's the challenge with the women
because you are the face yeah you are
that's the whole like that's like the
whole idea is like I'd be going through
wife school and I'd be like I'd be
giving feedback each round so I'd be
like all right I'll try this this week
I'll try that you know so it's like I
love it so because it reminds me of Anna
Bay School of Ellie School of affluence
yeah no I don't know what that is so
Annabeth called affluence she was the
one she created she very popular YouTube
channel for women teaching women how to
be affluent how to marry men in High
Society this down in the third yeah so
her information was like you said very
biographical as garyvee says document
don't create I'm not Theory I'm
documenting the journey and then
eventually she gets married gives all
types of credibility so you're 100 right
if you're gonna go that route where it's
like hey guys I'm not there yet I need
to learn I need to grow I need to
improve here are these expert women but
the point that I was bringing up was
that the true power in it when you go
bananas is when you're like yo I went
through wife school and I got married
yeah cause you're the face of it you're
the one bringing everybody together you
are the face no matter what you can
bring some amazing women on to Wife
School wife Academy whatever you call it
but you're gonna be the face but when
you're able to come in that room and be
like yo lady welcome to White School
episode one my I'm your host Jess pearly
and and ladies no no I said I'm not I'm
going through it I'm talking about in
the future yeah yeah okay how many how
many times you're going through white
school
no no what's up season one
season seven right now I didn't know
you're talking about season two I was
talking about we got to do one before
seven okay I'm giving season seven right
now okay
I'm using season seven this is how this
is how Stephen seven is gonna begin hey
how you doing today ladies it's just
pearly things and this is season seven
of Life School as you guys know oh
it worked for me you know and then you
know I mean you start flexing and I'm
telling you yeah women like women who
are where they want to be and so to me
one of my biggest things and like I said
just it's just I love what you said I
want to see more of that I want to see
that there's enough we know women modern
women are delusional we know the issues
in the divorce court we know that we
know these and we don't need more of it
we need you yeah but helping women I
disagree with you because like the one
thing I think it's it's common in our
space of YouTube to know this but it's
not common in like the general like I'm
on volleyball teams I'm on basketball
team like I I deal with a lot of
different types of girls from all walks
of life I don't think it's most girls
have any idea and that's actually part
of the stuff on my channel is like I
read pill women so I'll show them Jordan
Peterson about the pay Gap or I'll I'll
show them like so it's kind of like you
kind of see them go through their
Journey like first time but but my but
my thing is that and this maybe this is
my criticism of doing it for seven years
and maybe you're just sorry seven years
so huh this is my criticism of me doing
this for seven years okay and also me in
this in the I'm helping men since
2012 when I when I dropped my first
YouTube video I'm obsessed with
Solutions and the best Solutions right
if you true if we truly believe doing
YouTube videos showing people what's the
what's wrong in today's world is going
to change the minds of the masses you
and I both know that is not the case you
and I both know that's not the case that
is not the long-term solution to society
if you were to ask me what what would
change the world more you know pearly
things doing a wife Academy or wife
school where she's going through things
that a wife needs to be successful that
she goes through herself and then all of
a sudden she finds an amazing husband
and now she's having an amazing family
and using this example versus just going
up to random girls asking her do you
believe in female privilege what what do
what is most effective and so to me
that's the part where I realize my
expectations is not fair to put it on
you because it's your life it's your
purpose whatever you feel like God's
calls you to do but to me I after doing
this for so many years I'm like yo the
win is is the receipt is a result that's
the win in today's society the winning
today Society is what all the 40 year
old plus feminists single miserable
lonely yeah and they're and they're
upset and then their friends are happily
married doing well that's the win Sean
like yo you guys thought that 40 that 40
and 40 and with your cats is cool look
at you now that's the win is the receipt
so to me I want I I just don't think we
need more women just simply doing what
the guys are doing we already have the
guys doing that why don't the women such
as yourself who have the who have the
intelligence who have the ability to
encourage equip build up other women why
don't you guys do more of that and I
guarantee you that's what I'm trying to
do where's the wife Academy at it's um
we want to launch it in like February
March listen listen if you are for real
yeah I'm like dead seriously no no I'm
serious yeah if you are for real and you
are truly doing this I want to see it in
February I'm gonna I'm gonna and I'm
gonna that listen I'ma get your
information I'm gonna put it on my
calendar I'm gonna put February the
launch of wife school and you and
because what's happened is as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible